I'm I'm doing a debate with a leading
archaeologist on The Joe Rogan
Experience on the 24th of October she'll
be happy that's his thing yeah it's it's
a very good thing that this is happening
it's the first time that somebody
representing the alternative point of
view has actually been debated by
somebody from the mainstream the
mainstream is normally said now we don't
want to talk to you guys you're you
you're Looney Tunes we're not going to
give you a platform but in this case it
is it is happening and um I have things
to say about Malta that I'm going to
preserve my ammunition for this can you
give us a taste can you give us a little
taste uh it's to do with the absolute
insecurity of the carbon dating do you
think there's any submerged pyramids
um just to finish that point carbon
dating by the way and again this is not
something that everybody knows carbon
dating can only date organic material it
can't date
um Stone so so if you're going to date a
megalith according to the organic
material found around you you want to be
pretty sure or that the organic material
dates from the same time as the
megalithm wasn't introduced later right
and there's no way in proving that it is
or it is
difficult yeah yeah it's very it's very
it's very difficult to do and the fact
is there there are very few common days
from Malta and the new dating work
that's been done there hasn't added
usefully to that database and when are
you doing this on uh Joe's part so 24th
of October
um and uh the the archaeologist who's
going to debate me is called Flint
Dibble
um he's American but he teaches at the
University of Cardiff in Wales in
Britain his father was a famous
archaeologist called Harold Dibble
um and uh Flynn Flint has been very
um pointed and aggressive in his attacks
on me following the Netflix show which
has every right to be I had wanted to
debate another archaeologist who's
called John hoops from the University of
Kansas because he has been by far the
most obnoxious in these leveling these
ad hominem attacks against me and and
straw man attacks like Hancock says this
Hancock says that when Hancock doesn't
say either this or that you know but if
you again if you say it enough uh it
begins to have an effect and I I would
have liked to have brought called John
Hoops to account
um and and invited him to debate me but
unfortunately he backed out and he
wouldn't he wouldn't do it Flint Dibble
and this is genuine Flint Dibble has had
some health issues I won't go into the D
details and we've not been certain until
very recently whether he will be able to
make it but kudos to him it looks like
he is going to make it and what he's
doing and what I'm doing
on the 24th of October is we're both
putting our reputations
this is a high stakes issue for both me
and him because you know anything can
happen in a debate and uh I I certainly
intend to make sure that I'm properly
prepared I'm sure he's going to make
sure he's properly prepared I hope we
can end up hugging each other and and
finding some common ground rather than
all of this hatred yeah okay